[Music]
hello dom we have returned to the
friendship onion studios incredible
friendship onion studios and i've
brought
your wonderful wife's designed t-shirt
can i clap your duck
can i clap your dug wonderful scottish
term there can i stroke your hound and
unfortunately william
i've tarnished it with a little bit of
smoothie what kind of smoothie is that
it looks as if it's a diarrhea one yeah
it does look like diarrhea um
this is called the express o as we know
express
it's an espresso in italy and all over
the world
but this is the expresso because i think
they didn't want to get maybe in trouble
with people thinking it's just an
espresso no no this is an espresso
that includes coffee beans some
chocolate some peanut butter it's very
tasty but it's also very stainy oh did
you get it on the t-shirt i've got it on
the t-shirt in in uh three different
places almost in a triangle
yeah how are you you've been away you've
been to mexico i did i had a little
vacation haven't had a vacation for a
while i don't think and then yeah me and
my son went down
to baja
and we had a little bit of a surf
session
and it was uh it was lovely the water
was nice yeah the weather was nice it
wasn't too hot mm-hmm it was a it was a
lovely little breakaway zombie you got a
wonderful tan you look very trimming you
got yourself a new haircut you're
showing up in a jazzy kind of jackety
type vibe yeah i was i was rushing out
the door and it's just uh this is all
russian well we'll have a russian person
hunted yes we've got a wonderful russian
uh guest well ukrainian well families
maybe maybe a combination of the two
combinations we'll talk about that later
yeah and you've been away uh surfing so
you've not you've not been quite on your
bulking schedule but obviously surfing
gets you big it gets you a big strong
back it was quite a long paddle outdoor
and uh the waves were lovely and uh i
feel as though i got some exercise but i
i kept eating as if i was balking so
that's the main thing great i think i'll
put on another five pounds good for you
well we should maybe consider getting a
pair of uh well not a pair
a set of weighing scales in here yeah
we'll get up here let's get two of them
just make sure that the
they're correct because i'm getting
smaller yes you're getting bigger
you could be like the amazing shrinking
man do you remember that movie yeah i
want to get it's interesting because
whilst you're bulking i'm trying to get
live
virtually what's your body fat oh it's
not a lot i would say my body fat's
probably in the 12 percentile 13
percentile i'm probably up about 75 body
fat yeah but you look fantastic oh i
look amazing i'll give you that tom
peeling the onion
hey should we do a bit of housekeeping
come on dom
how's keeping
wow
to keep our house so nice and true on
you go bills go on jocelyn from manitoba
canada uh says listening to you guys
trying to figure out the geography of
canada was painful oh yeah it was quite
painful actually um jocelyn says but
overall
i was very impressed thank you i was
also not surprised that manitoba was the
one province that you hadn't heard of
because apparently we aren't known for
anything special and we'll normally
skipped over ah that's a shame at
manitoba i've heard of it before however
my tiny town of about 1 000 people is
famous for having the world's largest
curling rock oh
have you ever tried carl and dom no i'd
like to it's like large um
what's the game in the pub shuffleboard
it's like exactly it's like a big big
rock it's a
anyway this is it's just
a giant statue randomly in our town my
question is
if there was a town named after you
what would be the statue world record
that you were known for statue
or world record
what would it be is what she's saying
if there was a town named after you dumb
monahan town down at the town of don
monan what can a statue or what what
would be what would be in that town i
think in the center of town in don mona
and town center there'd be a picture of
me
in a gamer chair
slaving over my laptop with my tongue
out to the side hopefully winning a game
of league of legends that would be the
town center everyone would say where
we're meeting tonight let's just meet at
the statue and it's me playing league of
legends
i think that'd be good i'll meet you at
the don monaghan
statue that's where people would meet
curling rocks
are made from granite
from only two places in the world dumb
goodness i thought it was only one
and it's called elsa craig is the
scottish one i don't know where the
welsh one is but there is a as a little
island and it's off the west coast of
scotland
uh and it's it's called elsa craig and
all the curling stones
come from there
so the ones that you see in the olympics
and all that kind of stuff is that is it
is there a density to them that you
don't find elsewhere there's something
about that granite that makes it right
slippy
you can throw it on ice and it will just
go forever as long as you get somebody
in front with that sweet brush i don't
know where in wales it comes from maybe
somebody out there could tell us um if i
had a town uh what would well it'd be me
in the bath wouldn't it tom are you in
the bath sweating with your with your
glasses on sideways just yeah just
enjoying some music a little speaker
there
maybe a nice glass of red wine
super hot bath like uncomfortably hot
does not sound great and then
what's the the latest thing i've i've
added to my bath it's just made it
perfect yeah you've added a candle of
seanaston there's a shawn aston candle
that have got a kind of religious candle
yeah he looks like a kind of an apostle
or a disciple maybe
oh yeah you're right one of the apostles
and uh i like that and then i've got
sean watching me in the bathroom i quite
enjoyed that mm-hmm okay all right billy
in the bath lovely question there from
jocelyn in manitoba got a question here
from charlotte in manchester
shout out to everyone in manchester
uh who said if the lord the rings story
was remade with dogs
what breed of dog would each character
be for reference my dogs are lassa
apsos is that right am i saying it right
i think so yeah lap so
lassa
maps us
lassa app sauce i don't know lap so
elabso lap subs elapses um small cheeky
and a little bit crazy like mary and
pippin well
what can i do why okay well we can't do
every character she's probably asking
for counters from
the fellowship
right yes the fellowship the nine so
they've done us that's two laps so
absolutes
i'm going to say that um
legolas is a an afghan hound definitely
definitely an afghan hound with a long
with a long straight hair they're crazy
looking things what about aragon
well initially i thought german shepherd
but is that a bit too tough no maybe
maybe that's right actually because it's
a noble beast doesn't it yeah okay well
that's aragorn covered how are we
feeling about um maybe gandalf is he an
old english sheepdog
oh lovely an old one
but still doing its best still smart
uh-huh a little bit slower than it used
to be yeah lovely borom egg
sam boromir another alsatian another
german shepherd slightly smaller
slightly smaller than that yeah i'll
give you that frodo frodos uh cauli a
cauli dog yes smart smart maybe a little
bit too small yeah i like that
sam what's the most loyal is he a
labrador golden retriever or a golden
retriever
and then who we missed left to someone
else isn't it oh gimli gimli what about
what lady i was going to say like a wire
terrier but bulldogs kind of good ah
bulldog come on yeah i like bulldog
right it takes no messing is that is
that the entire fellowship i think
that's it four five six seven eight nine
i want a thing me in there though uh
or what are they called again big uh a
great dane who could be a great dean
i mean who's the biggest guy in the
fellowship
gandalf or aragon really yeah well maybe
not the fellowship there so he's not
part of the fellowship but you know
those hairless um dogs from mexico yeah
like completely hairless dogs yeah like
little that's got them right yeah gold's
one of those hairless chihuahuas it's
gotta be golem
question good question i've got one more
here charlotte yeah of course oh this
from youtube on you girl this is sarah
from youtube now i think this is a great
idea and i think you'll agree it's a
great idea i don't know
would you guys ever consider doing a fan
art day oh fine art for not like put up
an announcement so we all know when it
is
a deadline so we can work towards it
then all of us artists nerds who love
mary and pippen can submit our art i
think that would be fun says sarah from
youtube that would be fun not only would
it be fun
we could do an entire episode just on
opening and uh talking about the fan art
because there's some fantastic fan art
comes in we've got great stuff but there
are some spaces behind like right here
look the space is rare thank you lovely
master look at all the space up here
above us
yeah joanna johnny close keeps saying
he's going to put stuff up there but he
never does i think it's better to have
people send stuff in well what should we
say should we say september sometime
well and in america they have labor day
don't they because that's what they say
that's when schools go back and stuff ah
which i think is september the fifth dom
okay let's do september the fifth
anytime if you send us stuff before
september the 5th we'll look through it
and then we'll do a special fanart
episode billion dolms for not episode so
please do whatever you do maybe you knit
things then knit as both a hat
if you um do oil paintings i would
suggest uh using oil paint or if you use
brass for sculptures then do one of me
in the bath and one of him playing
league of legends yeah talking to league
of legends so we do an update yes
that was a big one how's it been well
our friend nigel has come to visit
staying with me since you went to mexico
and uh we've been playing side by side
like brothers in arms well the the thing
about
nigel is that we we all may unload the
rings so we ask them to be a guest on
here yeah
to tell us all about his experiences
unload the rings but he decided to sit
outside and then not bother doing that
he's refused he's he's point-blank
refused
yeah i think we probably could not only
was he on set he was probably on average
on set more than us because he had to
come to work every single day and there
were days here and there where we
weren't working and it went on so long i
think he had many jobs on that yeah it'd
be an interesting chat interesting he's
a kiwi knows all about new zealand and
knows about filming in new zealand he's
been playing league of legends with us
since pretty much day one and he's
refused so tell us about your league
alleged set up with nigel well i've
never played um i've never won five
games in a row and we won five games in
a row the other night and then we sat
down and said i wonder why that is and
we both agreed that maybe
sat next to each other there's a there's
a synergy there's a there's a free song
between my family and my business life
i've enough to worry about i need the
peace of mind of identity protection but
how do i know what protection i need
that's why i use allstate identity
protection the best of identity
protection from a brand you can trust so
much of life is logging into our digital
lives that's why allstate developed an
identity protection product that
protects your digital life just like
they do your physical life with allstate
identity protection they'll reimburse up
to a million dollars for out-of-pocket
expenses lost wages and legal fees
they'll also cover money stolen from
your bank accounts 401ks hsas and tax
returns at allstate they've been
protecting the things people love for
over 90 years not only will they monitor
to help keep you safe but should
identity theft ever occur their us-based
customer care identity specialist
provide expert support 24 7 365 with an
industry-leading 98
satisfaction score got a big or growing
family you can enroll your entire
household under one family plan spouse
kids parents in-laws all for a flat rate
that's less than you would pay for two
individual plans and without the typical
age or residency restrictions of where
they live think the identity protection
your bank provides is enough think again
the reality is that most financial
institutions act only after fraud occurs
rather than preventing it having
comprehensive monitoring and coverage
from aip will help stop identity thieves
in their tracks before any major damage
is done what i love about allstate
identity protection is the peace of mind
it provides so when you think identity
protection think allstate identity
protection to find out if your employer
offers all-state identity protection
head to
aip.com if not get a 30-day free trial
at aip
one last time that's aip.com
so you were sitting how close to each
other would you say well my desk
unfortunately at my house is not that
big
so we were pretty close i would say
there was a distance of around about a
quarter of a foot between us and did you
have on your gamer headphones no you
just talked to each other just put the
sound through my monitor right and we
didn't play with uh headsets which meant
that our other friend andrew who wanted
to play i said unfortunately we're not
on
headsets because we're just talking to
each other so andrew said okay i'll sit
this one out well that's a shame for
andrew it was a shame for andrew uh but
it was great for us because we won five
in a row never done that before and we
jumped around played teemo played miss
fortune played lux nige played uh
misfortune he played pike
he played viga
we smashed him five in a row for people
who don't know when you play league of
legends depending on how
who you're playing with
if it's better players then you play
other players on the other team who are
better you know so they match the sort
of levels and the thing is andrew is
actually better than all of us isn't he
so when he does play with us
we're playing better people way better
so you might not have got your five wins
if we'd have played with andrew true and
also
as you win they also ramp up the quality
oh do they yeah
so by the fifth game it was probably
difficult what knight and i was saying
we were saying maybe we want to lose one
relatively soon here because the
standard is going up but then we just
thought now let's just keep going let's
go
so we won five in a row and i think we
lost two or three in a row so you guys
played like eight games of league of
legends no it's just one one time that
we did five in a row and then the night
or the day after we played and we lost
three in a row and as you know when we
lose nigel's voice goes very deep
i think that's a lot dave doesn't like
you yeah so we had lost one night and i
said i'm off to bed night and you said
i'm gonna play one more on my own just
to see if i can get a win yeah you get
to bed put the lights out and you you
gotta you got a loss then a win so
that's your league of legends update
there we go um
yeah tell us what you guys are doing on
league of legends and if you've got any
tips also give me
give me some tips because i still don't
know how to play specifically high
madinger tips because that's who you
play or
tips on
as to how you unlock your camera and
don't feel like a
a ruddy fool when you do it because you
still play with a lock camera don't you
i still play with the lock camera and
also i still don't get things like
you know
three hits and then your foot is harder
like what's all that i don't get all
that stuff
yeah i'd like to know how all that works
though yeah because sometimes your
abilities will make your basic abilities
way stronger so sometimes it's like
do your cue back then do an a then do
another queue and then your second day
is like three times more powerful yeah
things like that but how do you know you
just have to kind of read about i
recommended reddit to you a while ago do
you remember and then i recommended a
reddit quantum physics page
while you're in mexico because i thought
you'll be coming in after a surf
you'll have that lovely poster feeling
in your body and in your mind when you
just kind of relax little glass of wine
a dozen oysters hopefully ones that
don't make you feel sick and then
you jump into a reddit quantum physics
uh chat he didn't do it
i didn't know did you have oysters that
made you feel sick though yeah death
did you try one of them and thought
not sure about that one yeah really and
i still ate it
now what does a bad or dodgy oyster
taste like i don't know just not quite
right and it was already in my mouth and
i was ready to put it out my mouth
and i thought ah
it's too much trouble
i just it's a little bit more trouble
later on right i just swallowed it and
then i felt bad last night i was sick
though
good job he went sick on the plane no i
was all right in the plane but when i
got to the house i felt oh i felt wheezy
and then i felt as if i was in the third
person i thought i was myself looking at
myself oh yeah
and then the second self
went into the toilet and it was coming
yeah
that wasn't good now could you talk me
through how does your personality change
when you're vomiting are you a tidy
vomiter do you cry do you get weak do
you sweat well it's quite it's it's uh
it's a private occupation well it is for
me i don't want anybody in there holding
my hair back or rubbing my back yeah you
tend to go through your sicknesses on
your own yeah i do i take my top off oh
not always okay not all sicknesses like
for instance a sprained ankle i wouldn't
take my top off i understand but if i'm
if i'm being sickened in the bowl yeah
which i haven't done for years sometimes
the t-shirt can feel like it's going to
stick to you it's too much isn't it so
yeah
and then i want you to feel the coolness
of it
i wouldn't feel the coolness of the the
the the pan but oh yeah you know that i
mean a pan is used for defecation i
don't want to touch it yeah you could
hug the base i don't know but i don't
know i don't know why i've been here the
basically yeah
porcelain thing against your cheek
so i just i was just i did what i could
and
how many how many vomits uh like i was
like
i hadn't eaten you know other than a
pack of skips
oh yeah that's bad you don't want to
follow bad oysters with a package oh my
gosh what happened
so i had so you know it was just it was
and then i had a lot of water because i
was trying to hydrate so it was like yes
it was just skip flavored water that was
coming up
and did you get my least favorite one is
the dry one you know nothing
no i never got it i never got to that
stage because it was always the prom
cocktail water that was
i was getting was your wife knocking the
name bailey
when i'm not when i'm not feeling good
she lets me she leaves you alone and
then if i commit sure
everything okay
and actually i feel like i'm in the
third person also sometimes you don't
want to be around another person when
you are going to vomit because you can
pass it on or you can yeah don't like
the domino effect that's exactly the
vomit effect
the whole street's puking they're
hearing you or maybe they're they're
catching a little the downwind of the
acid in the toilet
everybody's got a top off
feel better today yeah i tell you i was
sat on a plane the camera was where i
think i was going to one of these
conventions which by the way toronto
end of september september the 28th
which is my birthday oh
we will be doing a live friendship onion
in the city of toronto which is in
canada if anybody is going and wants to
bring me a gift for my birthday please
do dom will get very jealous so please
bring gifts for him as well i do get
jealous when billy gets gifts also if
you'd like to attend the french bunion
live taping in uh toronto you can get
all that information at fan expo toronto
online come see us we'd love to see you
there we'll be doing a birthday
extravaganza celebration for billy can't
wait i was on a plane going to one of
these conventions
and a lovely gentleman
he was probably in his early 70s i would
say
came and sat down next to me
and um the plane hadn't taken off yet
and he reached for what i thought was
going to be kind of a magazine and he
pulled out a sick bag and i thought oh
no i'm gonna watch this just to be
mindful
he opened it up and he had it opened in
his lap right
and it just kind of gave him a couple of
little side glances when he wasn't
watching sweat just commenting
and at that point i thought i should
probably ask if you're all right would
you want anything i said are you okay
and he looked at me and gave me a lovely
smile he said i'm a very nervous flyer
so i'm sorry i said would you want some
water or something he said no i'm okay
and then the s duodes saw said the same
thing he said i'm fine as soon as the
air
plane started to pick up a little bit of
the
pace with the wheels and stuff he shot
his eyes
i was going deep breathing and i just
thought
there's a chance here that i might get
caught in some of the ricochet but he
just passed out i think he had actually
asked for just a tonic just a tonic
water and when they came he was asleep
yeah and the lady kind of looked at me
and she said do you want it and i said
yeah stuck a gin in it
but i've never been sick on a plane but
he looked like he was pretty
touch-and-go this man i don't think i've
ever been sick in a point no i get
excited that one time you got really
sweaty
on the plane no
oh no that was lost i remember in there
sorry
yeah that was the character that i
played on the last who was a heroin
addict and i think
flying when you're doing cold turkey is
supposed to be that's not for the best
no not for the best dog there's one left
you want to do it oh i'll do it there we
go this is from emily in arizona lovely
part of the united states very hot who
said re the film light year which we got
into a while ago said hi uh dom and
billy my name is emily i live in arizona
i love the podcast i wanted to help
billy with his distress over the film
lightyear in case you didn't know there
was an entire animated series when i was
a kid based on the idea that there was a
real buzz lightyear out there that the
buzz in toy story as an action figure is
based on he and his team go on all kind
of universe saving adventures and fight
their arch nemesis
zerg i would assume that the new movie
is more of a nod to this animated series
than the original toy story film hope
that helps you go to the movie with a
little less distress i'll tell you right
now emily billy is not going to see that
film i still don't
cause here right
if buzz lightyear the toy that we know
from toy story is based on a real buzz
lightyear
a real astronaut right
who goes into space
and fights zorg
and all these other people then
the planet that that toy is in
we would know all about zorg and all
that um well we do know about zerg but i
wanted to feature in the toy story only
through the toys only from the top like
the mum and dad
of the boy i see what you're saying they
don't say oh i wonder what's
happening it doesn't seem like the
planet where we're at war with
another
you know alien race i understand so what
you're saying is in toy story it's a
very self-contained issue between toys
it's just a toy thing it's not a world
thing and then suddenly in the
light-year thing they're saying there
actually was a real human astronaut that
went and fought these battles and you're
like well that breaks the whole well
that yeah i think their mum and dad
would be talking about that they'd be
saying should we send our son to space
school yeah to fight zorg i understand i
understand i still have problems no
you're very i should go and see it
before i say anything yeah no you're
very strict over um
the whole you're very strict over the
whole um sci-fi thing i like things to
have rules
i guess i've just heard
i just read did you hear it or read it
you're very passionate about both of
those i just read it okay and you heard
it in your mind they are making a movie
of rendezvous with rama
i have no idea what that is it's one of
my favorite sci-fi books really
i'd like to be in it rama the kind of
god
rama is this spaceship that comes we
don't know where from and it enters our
solar system we don't know it's just a
spaceship it's just a big shape
and we send up astronauts and they go
inside
and it's it's hollow
there's nothing and very quickly it
starts to evolve oh this is the book
that you keep talking about evolution
rapidly rendezvous with rama you are
being that how it being how how do we
make that happen i think maybe just ask
people out there to start a petition
start a petition you'd be great i'd like
to be the captain yeah
okay let's work on that
brilliant thanks hey we've got a guest
this week william don
yeah are you going to do the intro i
think you should you're a much better
reader are you ready yeah
because this is very interesting and
very exciting for us are you ready
anya zova anjazova is a comedian actress
and professional athlete
born in the soviet union and raised by
ukrainian mother and russian father she
worked in the wwe competing in their
developmental territory nxt wrestling
under the ring name anya she is a
founder of acting school miami and
yazova and author of zova's acting
technique now her
real name or or a given name was
bogamazova lovely how's that i love it
i'll better ask when she comes in bob
gamazova graduated law school and won
the kickboxing world cup in 2011. wow in
2020
bogamazova made her debut on the us
television sitcom brooklyn nine-nine and
tv series macgyver in april 2022 she
toured the uas with her own comedy show
make laughs not war which is really
interesting i want to talk about that in
support of ukraine
and in uniting people so please welcome
on to the friendship onion anjazova
hello anya
hi
i'm good i'm very happy to be here it's
lovely to see you yes it is lovely to
see you
what have you been up to today
uh today i worked out
replied to some emails and drove here
what is your general workout we've been
talking about workouts we're doing
opposite things he's trying to get super
lean
stripped i'm trying to get big
but like bulky you want to get like bugs
i want to get like as big as i can get i
just eat a lot of protein i'm i'm doing
that i'm just eating non-stop i don't
think i'm lifting enough weights i just
eat yeah it doesn't work that way so you
need to lift weights what is your
workout these days well because i used
to be an athlete yeah i have so much
muscle memory so if i start waiting uh
doing heavy weights i get bulky and i'm
going to look like a man and i don't
want to look like a man so i do like my
own with my own body weight exercises
like heat workout and i found out this
new surgical is pure bar it's kind of
like ballet club but it's not balancing
that's what billy's wife does oh i have
teaches yeah
where which one which location i i don't
know if i'm allowed to say okay no no no
no she does we'll do that
yeah but i love it i go well i'm not
gonna say where i go but yeah i go to a
couple of studios in the la for me i
start seeing changes in my body like
after three weeks i'm like this is
magical isn't it good it's well you see
your wife always attempt right yeah i
see her every day she looks amazing
right yeah incredible
it's the best workout ever well that's
great to hear listen to that ally see
andrea loves it there you are yeah she's
probably been your teacher at some point
that's amazing you guys can talk
together i'll make sure that you i love
it honestly for women i feel like it's
the best workout ever it just leans you
down like you want to get lean this is
what you need to do i would like to get
lean so my thing is why don't you do
pure bar yeah yeah and also flexible
right yeah you get is this one guy who
always comes to our gym it's a little
bit weird it's like 10 women and one guy
but everybody's smart yes he's smart but
everybody welcomes him and he's like so
you should do it i would like that now
because the thing with me and you is
even though you might not you see it
very easily and it is quite an
affliction
i'm quite tight in my hips
i know
this is something you can work on but
for men it's normal men to be tight in
the hips yeah but usually women are more
loose in their hips and this is what
like it's our nature you know it's okay
so if you do stretch and
stretching is something you can do every
day my wonderful mother hello momo had a
double hip uh replacement i don't want
to have a double hit replacement but i
think i'm on my way well you've got to
do you got to do some squats you see
okay keep it strong
now you were a kickboxing world champion
is that fair to say yes i was back in
2010.
that is that's incredible meme dom have
talked about this before to be world
champion at anything
is
that what
what a thing a place to be in your head
yeah that at some point in the history
of mankind in this world
you were the greatest at something yeah
i just feel like it's normal maybe to
like this desire to be like the best at
something yeah and i remember when i was
a kid like my kid my parents brought me
like two calisthenics like rhythmic
gymnastics uh-huh but i was very tall
and muscular i was skinny kid but i was
like taller than anybody else and like
at some point like after four years
doing it and my coach's like well listen
she's not gonna get anywhere with that
just
you guys have to quit you know so i quit
that and i'm like what i'm gonna do but
like my father always wanted a son you
know so like i remember always had like
boxing gloves he always has a boxing bag
and now a house in russia so like all
this was like he was try to box try to
box and then he's like well for self
defense you're like you're 14 like you
know you hang out with all the girls
yeah like and back then in russia was
like like something always happens like
in russia something happens like you
cannot have your phone on you like your
jewelry like you're getting robbed like
on streets every day okay so like for
self-defense why don't you do that and
he brought me to the gym i was the only
girl um all the boys in the gym and
i loved it and i started doing very well
i'm like oh she brought me to nationals
after like six months of training which
i was not ready at all
and i lost and after i lost i was like
i'm going to do whatever it takes never
never lose again
so it was a head space
where where was this in russia i grew up
in baroness it's south east of moscow
like six-hour drive okay well my mom is
ukraine if i was russian but i was
raised in russia so all my life i
consider myself russian i did a lot of
martial arts when i was younger what
kind all all sorts i did then bruce
lee's art mm-hmm and i did filipino cali
what is that it's like stick fighting
from the philippines and i did um muay
thai
and the thing i could never get over is
getting hit i never like getting hit
how do you get up like
you know what i mean when you when you
when you went a spa
and like you'd learn everything and then
someone punches you in the faces it's a
horrible feeling it is but it's gonna
sound horrible but you're kind of
getting used to that
so you just sort of got used to it you
get used to it and it's at the beginning
it hurts like like everything hurts like
even your legs from kicking somebody
hurts but it's eventually like okay it's
not that bad and you just you don't take
it as a
i'm hurt right now this is just a state
you're such you're very focused when you
do martial arts like you 100 in the
moment if you zoom out you gone right so
i feel like this sport teaches you like
to be in the moment well any sport you
have to be like if you serve you have to
be in the moment yeah so you 100 a
moment you don't think about pain it's
going to hurt after okay after the
sparring moment and the moment nothing
hurts and you were mainly based in
taekwondo is that right i also did
taekwondo because um i was like super
flexible after gymnastics and like
i would throw my legs over my opponent's
head right
and my coach is like okay you're not
allowed to stretch for like a couple of
months because we need to like bring
your flexibility a little bit down right
or face somebody taller yeah but it's
hard like one like like you know there
are not that many tall guys to spar with
women forget about it so yeah i did
taekwondo to help me with pop kicks and
my coach he was boxer so alexander
combined both techniques together and
then it works but i'm like had a huge
advantage i didn't get punched as much
as other people because i'm tall
and it's all about learning the
technique like klitschko like they tall
like why is they became champions and
boxing because they developed this
technique where you don't let your
opponent come close to you uh so you're
always keeping them away all this on a
distance always so i know if i let them
in i'm gonna lose and you you're
constantly jabbing jabbing all the time
jabbing and there's a front kick
constantly like
constantly right you don't have to like
otherwise i know if i get in close
distance i'm gonna be gone because my
leg uh arms are longer so it takes some
it doesn't matter how quick i am it's
still gonna take for me longer for my
punch to reach
and you you had you had quite a famous
um coach right a russian coach he's
pretty famous now yeah he's um big his
uh race to multiple champions yeah i was
the only girl like he he didn't want to
take me and he was muslim he's still
muslim um russian muslim and he's like i
don't train girls like he's like he's
like is there only guys in the gym
you're gonna distract them and they was
like please i was begging he was like
okay you can wear only like baggy
clothes
wear a bandana cover your hat
and he's like i'm not gonna pay
attention to you just copy whatever they
do so for like entire like i would say
first seven eight months i was just
copying whatever guys were doing he
wouldn't let me spar but then he saw me
not giving up he was like okay now i can
put you two
yeah now do you do you watch any uh we
were just talking about before the show
started do you watch any ufc not as much
as i used to if it's like yeah it's hard
sometimes to watch like i know how hard
it is for them you know look at the
experience the pressure and like there's
like money involved and they have
families and defeat you know so but i do
i love mma i love boxing because they
obviously combine a lot of different
styles there's a huge amount of
greco-roman wrestling in there and
jujitsu but there is quite a lot of
kickboxing too right there is a lot of
wrestling too like and wrestling is hard
i feel like like grappling and jujitsu
it's even because you
waste so much energy on wrestling
because you put your entire body weight
on it
so yeah i inspire like if those guys had
more of them whatever it does it's the
hardest thing ever yeah i think i think
those combat sports there's something
really kind of
i don't know
so real about it isn't it i mean any
other sport you're like okay there's
there's this involved are the cars
involved but this is just two people
saying okay who's going to win this
chess match between us
and so so you went from the the
kickboxing
then into wrestling right well yeah when
i moved to the states i was like okay
what do i do now like in kickboxing kind
of did everything i wanted like you win
the world cup what else are you gonna do
yeah so and it's not olympic sport yet
like i say we've been trying to make it
olympic for many years um hopefully one
day we're really hoping for that so i'm
like okay what do i do i switch to
boxing do i switch to mma because boxing
is female boxing now olympic i'm like
okay that's that's good because i was
always i would love to be in olympic
games and then i got approached by wwe
and like do you watch wrestling i'm like
not really like i know like it's a rock
i know yeah yeah i know if you like rick
flair you know like i know
hulk hogan yeah he's like why don't you
watch wrestling and we would like to
invite you for tray out uh in tempe back
then i was living in miami like in
temple like five hour drive
come for a week
train with us and we'll see and i was
like okay so i did that and i remember i
walked into the gym i was like it's like
four different rings and it's like very
like you see people working really hard
and i'm like oh this is not fake at all
like you see those bombs and they're
falling for real and they just
somebody's just jumping from the ropes
and those guys are huge yeah like on the
cow like with this body weight it's not
easy like i've been doing gymnastics i
couldn't do it because i was too big for
that yeah how was it doing it yeah and i
thought like i remember my first
trainings i just some the guy pulled me
up and like body slammed me i'm like wow
that hurt maybe i left pain i don't know
what it is
i was like that hurts i want to learn
how to do that
and uh i just had tremendous respect for
them after i saw the training
it's not fake it's not ballet it's not
like what people think it is yes it's
choreographed you know who's gonna win
but all the moves are real like you have
to be really
um yeah they're athletes
yeah absolutely and they did acting like
i remember my favorite part was like
once a week we had acting coach dusty
rose was like famous
wrestler he
back then i fell in love with acting i'm
like this is fun they put like you know
in front of camera all the wrestlers sit
behind the camera and for 30 seconds or
one minute you can say whatever you want
to say like you challenge somebody you
know right yeah you talk [ __ ] about
somebody and i'm like i'm allowed to do
that
like yeah that's what they're supposed
to be supposed to be mean i'm like okay
and that's what got you interested in
acting
so just to go back a little bit so
you're in russia
what made you think
so you're a world champion
and you thought i i want 11 america or
did something bring you to america
a good question growing up i felt like i
always wanted to move not because my
life was bad like i mean my family went
through we were rich or poor rich
against them very poor again so it's a
lot of ups and downs
but
i always felt like i want to be
abroad like i want to challenge myself i
always knew i'm going to move i remember
when i was like 16 i found a college in
canada and i begged my parents to sign
their release form for me to leave and
my father wouldn't do it he was like no
you like after graduate college in
russia do whatever you want and i was
crying and crying and then was
eventually went to school in russia and
after grade i'm like okay where do i go
and i knew some professional boxers in
miami and i know i can train with them
and they can help me out so i'm like
okay let me go at least where i know
some people
so i will i feel like
i always wanted to leave but not because
life was bad just i had the best
childhood ever like you grow up on the
streets in russia you know it's not here
he's like not allowed to be on the
streets like you grow up on the streets
you learn from other kids
i just wanted to challenge myself like
i'm like let's do something different
and and with your parents being so
they're here with you now they're in the
states so they would have grown up in um
communist uh russia communists this i
think actually one of the reasons why we
live because my father is very outspoken
and very free spirit and in russia you
cannot do that right like they used to
have a newspaper and there was since
putin became like a president like my
entire family was like struggling
because you cannot express yourself like
like there's no freedom of speech like
right like and my father grew up in that
environment like you cannot say like he
was almost went to jail because when he
was in high school he was selling jeans
he was buying jeans from international
students right african-americans and he
was reselling them right and that was
illegal which is now considered business
back then it was illegal right and he
almost well to this junior how you call
it like um
prison for teenagers yeah like a poster
yeah so nowadays it's it's called
internship like you just become a
businessman you know doing that you sell
it on ebay on amazon and so and he was
always i think i also was programmed
like by him like hey you need to live to
the country where you have freedom you
where you can express yourself
and yeah
so with a with a russian father and a
ukrainian mother
and with what is very unfortunately
going on right now in that part of the
world
how do those conversations come up with
the three of you guys and you're all
obviously all in the states now we're
all in the states yeah how have you
approached that with with your mom and
dad and maybe your extended family are
they still in russia yeah i have i have
uh uh relatives on both sides i have
relatives in ukraine and my one uncle is
in mario another uncle kiev and my dad's
relatives in russia but my father is
very pro-ukrainian from the day one like
he's very political my father's very
politic has a hundred of opinions
and um
he supports ukraine from day one so they
almost like when crimea conflict
happened my parents even up back then
they were in russians they opened like a
medical center free medical services
from people from crime from area areas
so they can get lagman because we had a
lot of refugees
so like we don't have any conflicts
about that so we're all on the same side
like we're against putin we're against
the regime we want to support ukraine um
but it's hard you know like when your
relatives are still in ukraine it's like
and sometimes i'm like i even feel
guilty i'm like i live this beautiful
life and like when they struggle there
yeah it's it's hard i mean we help as
much as we can but it's yeah you just
feel like here in a bubble you know did
a film in ukraine in crimea oh wow
i don't know 10 years ago now
christian slater
sean bean
bing rhames myself
um
yeah we're in crimea for i think
five or six months something like that
and how was your experience like just
with people the
with people we worked a lot it was a
beautiful part of the world lots of kind
of countryside and
you know beaches and stuff
the crew were lovely
try i think what were the stuff i mean
very strong
vodka vodka
it seemed to be a tradition because
they're called garil
yeah maybe yeah
was a tradition on a friday when we
finished to take like the
the row the eggs of of fish
people would put it on their hand here
you take a shot of this the vodka and
then this caviar yes people would just
come around the party more more more
vodka more vodka so very fast drinking
yeah and you cannot say no right they
can't say no it's rude
so you'd have to make excuses to leave
otherwise
you know you finish at six and by twenty
past six you've had like
eight shots of vodka
i gotta go home i gotta go but it's
beautiful the weather was incredible
really warm and sunny and beautiful
and it's the first time i'd seen sean
bean in a long time in fact sean bean we
were on set
chatting one day and sean said what i do
did this really great show
uh
a couple months ago i thought you really
like it but not not sure what it's gonna
if it's gonna be good or not it's on hbo
it's called there game of thrones
i was like oh okay yeah that went okay
yeah yeah he was he was like fantastic
but he wasn't sure if it was going to
find an audience meanwhile it becomes
the biggest show
on tv you know so yeah beautiful
memories in ukraine yeah i'm glad you
had a good experience yeah it was
fantastic so you so you're doing um to
try and uh help the people of ukraine
you're doing a comedy tour just now is
that right yeah i do with cosmic loves
not war to support ukraine we did first
show in march in comedy store like 100
from ticket sales went to charity global
environment mission i do whatever i can
now i'm on a tour
hopefully we're going to do another one
in caroline's uh
broadband career lands in new york also
100 ticket sales go to charity and
when's that going to be do you know if
we think in october and october october
yeah i wouldn't do it right i want to
have like one household comedian big
name and the rest of like russian and
ukraine comics we do comedy in english
but uh uh-huh for like just support
ukrainian yeah i was watching you online
very funny oh thank you yeah thank you
not only could you beat me up
the perfect woman
do you touch upon what is occurring in
ukraine or do you just have ukrainian
comedians come on and talk about funny
things so we talk about the work like
maybe not a hundred percent of the set
yeah but like i feel like people expect
us yeah like like make a statement like
what what are your where do you stand
yeah so like we do we do talk about even
like american comedians always like have
their opinions and jumping into the
table and yeah trying to you know
it's hard to make fun of the war but
we're not making fun of the world right
we're making fun of people who created
the war yeah yeah yeah i mean i think
it's really important and and you know
comedy has always been important for
kind of
um
getting across kind of difficult ideas
and difficult thoughts
and um i think you could argue just now
that it's getting more difficult for
comedians because they get scared to say
the wrong thing
it is and that is the people sensitive i
know like they cancel the cancer culture
and comedy has to push those boundaries
it has to because that's how we get
ideas it's through art it's through
plays and comedy and
you know we have we have to let our
comedians say
difficult things sometimes because um it
can it can change ideas and it can
change the world really yeah yeah we are
living in a very
uh tricky time
for a lot of artists but i have felt
like comedians more than anyone else are
really at the forefront of that because
like you said bills
most of the time a smart comedian will
be
leaning towards the subjects that are a
little hard to talk about you know
you're not we've obviously we've
obviously done the whole you know
flying in planes and staying in hotels
type of comedians but now you know the
ones that are really making a difference
are the ones talking about
these things that are a little difficult
to talk about and if you're not given a
platform where you can take some risks
and take some chances that doesn't
include someone saying you said that one
word we never want to hear from you
again then what does what chances are
for us to stand at comedian they're
always about being risky you know and
you have to if you want to be good you
have to be risky you have to be like
right on the edge right it's like
and i feel like still in comedy we still
have more freedom of speech more than
anywhere else but some comics are asking
like because you don't want to get
canceled right yeah so it's like there's
a fine line all the time but
i do agree with both of you like i feel
like stand up comedy is something that
might save us because we need this like
outlet for like what do you guys do
podcast that's amazing
it's a freedom of speech express your
opinion publicly you know that's
wonderful that's like that's what we all
need to do like do you have comedy
heroes stand-up comedian heroes that are
kind of your
i think
i'm thinking nowadays well among women i
love sarah silverman yeah she's she just
makes a podcast next door no way yeah
yeah that's awesome i love her she's
fantastic she's fantastic funny smart
you know like like she's and she always
also like right on the edge you know
like she's right there yeah love her
well if you talk about
it so there are not that many political
comedians nowadays because
look it's dangerous like we were looking
like when we're going through the castle
we want to attach to the show i'm like
well sorry not that many like you know
it's like it's a lot of people talking
about relationships like airplanes you
know like yeah and if you're if you're
doing a show that's uh make laughs not
war and you're
you're going to talk about the war
you're going to talk about russia you're
going and then people are like oh
scared to cross a line somewhere as
you're saying
you you might not be able to
go to russia now i mean you'll be able
to go but whether you can get out again
yeah that's my father pointed out he's
like because i do a lot of charity like
i support like ukrainians and we do like
global empowerment mission one of the
charity organizations and but also
publicly express my opinion right about
putin and what is really wrong what he
does
uh if i go to russia i'll be able to go
but i'm not sure if is that easier to
leave because when you leave the airport
they check your instagram they check
your
so i'm not famous and i mean i'm famous
by my legal name they don't know is over
so it's kind of easier because i have a
second name now like stage name but
they're gonna check and even on the
street sometimes people get like pull
over by randomly you walk on the street
and police officer comes to you and hey
like give me your phone oh and it goes
through your instagram your facebook
your emails your text messages and just
anything you say a little bit sketchy
sounds a little bit sketchy like for
putin they're gonna arrest you that's a
real
dangerous time i mean that that
place in the world over there is so
wonderful as well for for art for high
art for you know bali and plays and i
mean it's so wonderful and it's a shame
that it's getting twisted into something
else huh it is it's i feel like it has
to stop like it's 2022 like yeah really
it's still happening like why is the
entire society entire world doesn't do
something
i'm just i just thought it was 2023
there no no honestly when you said it's
2022 i was going to correct you and i
was like wait hang on a second i might
have got this wrong
it is 2022 right yeah i live in the
future that's what happens as we get
older things get all mixed up tom what's
going on i don't know what's going on
tell us what's going to happen 2023 if
you live there yeah
well hopefully uh we'll be winning more
games of league of legends william
and billy and i will go billy just got
back from an amazing surf holiday and
and hopefully at some point in 2023
we can go on a little surf trip together
have you ever tried surfing i would love
to we'll invite you because we might
need protection down in mexico and
you've got a hell of a kick well from
yes but not from the sharks i cannot for
the difference
i think you could kick a shark i could
why not i should have yeah i mean what
about life what life you're leading yeah
i mean so and then even like the acting
so did the acting come from the
wrestling yes
acting in russian yeah i never acted i
always wanted to act in russia but it's
like in russia it's hard like in order
to be an actor in russia you have to go
to university and study for five years
to get your master's
so it's not like here you go to acting
school you'll pick up some skills and
you go to audition and um
yeah you just could just look pretty you
know in a restaurant and they're like
you you come on you're you're in the
marvel movies oh you're tick tock famous
then right yeah oh don't you billy under
ticked he's gonna lose his marbles but
but yeah you're right because i actually
studied a little while in poland
and the way that they study for acting
even compared to britain
like we we were doing some
um a check off over there and those guys
would go in at like six in the morning
to do a gym workout and then work on
their voice and voice and body
everything i mean
it's super serious it is so so you
didn't do that no i was like my parents
were like okay i need to get like a real
career like okay i don't go so i went to
be a wrestler
[Laughter]
almost well i went to law school did
that and then i was like when i moved
here i'm like okay this is maybe i can
try it and in wwe this is when i really
liked it like it was it was fun it's
like you feel free you can become
another character you can create a
character it's like wow i feel like a
child again you know like when you
become just playful you find this
playfulness inside of you and yeah after
wwe
i found an agent
uh and kind of everything like took off
from there i mean i didn't do that big
one i did brooklyn nine-nine that was
fun so how did that that was just an
edition uh it was an audition for my
agent and they were looking for russian
actor actress and uh back then i was
living in miami so my agent had to lie
and she's like well she's a lay base
so i flew in and worked like la based
and then eventually i moved here so
wow fantastic
it is play that's the that's the funny
thing i think with actors
who do it for a living
when they are hanging out with people
who are not necessarily working in
something that is play orientated
is that
i think we underestimate maybe just how
important players in our life like it's
something that i need to do it's
probably the reason why i play
computer games it's the reason why i
love board games it's the reason why i'm
always looking for like a joke or
something silly even though i do enjoy
that i think it does speak to the job
that i do because
just for me personally
to do the best job that i can do on a
film set i have to be in a state of play
i have to make sure that the crew are
kind of in a state of play and my cast
members if it gets too serious or too
earnest i feel like the options are
limited and i want to see if there's
more and more options so the play thing
is not to be underestimated
yeah it gives you a spark right like you
feel like playful easy childish i
remember you from lost right
yeah i sent your picture in my damn like
look who's gonna interview me he's like
oh my god because we all watched lost
and remember back then it was no netflix
not like networks so we had to buy dvds
yeah and i remember i went to
london like for two weeks i had like
exchange program for students and i
found those lost dvd for sale and i was
so excited that i could bring them home
to my parents that was like second
season or third season was like such a
treasure you know like you know the last
that was a great show i love that show
it's funny as well because i've met over
the years
i remember certainly in russia in saint
petersburg
the
russian person who does my voice in
russia so he said to me i did your voice
in lord of the rings i did your voice in
last
so then he said you have to keep working
give me my job just another extra
pressure there but i wonder what my
voice sounds like in in russian
hopefully similar it's really high
i'll find the clip i'll send it to you
yeah yeah so is that your as your main
drive now um the stand up and but still
acting you still still act yeah but like
once i fall in love with standard black
for about four years ago like it it like
took over my life i was like wow because
in russia we don't have stand up like
nowadays i left the rush like 11 years
ago and this is when the stand-up
started in russia so back then we had
nothing like we had sketch comedy like
what's the landscape president of
ukraine did like it did sketch
so we did like we did that we had that
but stand-up comedy just started there
and when i moved here i'm like i found
it like stand-up comedy this is fun and
you kind of have a little bit more
control over your career you know yeah
like yeah you still
you there are no auditions but you have
to make connections with bookers and
members of the clubs but you write your
own material like nobody controls you
humbly like you can be on stage every
night if you want to they're open mics
so when i found that i'm like wow this
is fun it's it keeps your brain always
on fire and yeah you have to keep your
opinion going
are you consistently trying how how long
is it would an act be for you are you
looking for us
like a 10 minute 15 minute time back
what it depends like i this make last
night war i had lines so i did like 30
to 40 minutes right on the road uh in
the late it's hard to do headlining gigs
because so many comics big comics so in
the late if i get 15 minutes set i'm
like i'm really happy yeah yeah yeah so
you do usually like five to 15 minutes
right so where can people see you just
now um well i just did improv on
saturday that was fun i did the cold
opening for
sebastian was on the show eric griffin i
was like damn this is so cool
with those guys yeah great people um i
have a actually show friday in um
hennington beach
yeah well is it jay leno's uh
no this is uh no i think it's i think
it's closed jelena does burping oh right
he does flowers he did have one by the
beach though right he did but i think
was before pandemic
yeah so i'm doing the ahmed ahmed show
in um sea grail in hennechton so it's
like on the beach but it's a big venue
so it's very cool oh great my this is
slightly well it's on topic but it's
like it's going to sound slightly random
at first my gardener
also works at another person's garden
and he said to me uh a few weeks ago he
was like hey
this person my other client is giving
away a whole bunch of like huge flower
pots because they're redoing their
garden do you want them and i said yeah
let me come around and see if that's
okay so i went ahead and saw i met
the the wife said hello we organized
buying the pots and then when i bought
the pots and he dropped them around i
realized that um that was bill burr's
wife and i love bill burr he might be my
favorite comedian right now did you see
his last special yeah on netflix
because there's a guy who says all right
i'm gonna
upset you guys abortion right 20 times
tonight yeah and you need to realize
that this is jokes of course i'm trying
to make a point but i'm trying to make
you think and have fun at the same time
you know he's brilliant bill amazing
amazing like this bit about abortion he
did at the end of the special was like
dan so brave you know like thank you
bill yeah yeah he's super brave so good
he that's a i just saw him last week he
did like there's a great venue called
supernova it's um in hollywood it's like
outdoors and it's looking they're like
3d screens all over the stage so it's
kind of psychedelic almost experience
and there's a comic on the middle of
stage i'm doing this when august 13th
and bill does this room all the time wow
so it's like what i like about the lady
you can see those big comics in like
random places like you know like it's a
show in hollywood under the stars yeah
and yeah bill is amazing he's brilliant
yeah
billy and dom eat the world
william should we eat the world well
yeah me and john like to eat the world
every week and obviously with anya here
it's going to be something sort of
russian a russian not only something
russian billy but something that will
remind us of a wonderful meal that you
and i had a couple of weeks ago really
yeah
billy and i finished about an hour early
from a convention
we were gonna go back to the hotel get
changed have a shower whatever go to the
airport and then we were like well we've
just bought ourselves an extra hour why
don't we grab a lunch on the way to the
airport and then you don't need to worry
about the potentially
dodgy food on the airplane went to a
fantastic seafood restaurant with mr
elijah jordan wood and we ate caviar and
blinis
and i believe these are bellini's right
mm-hmm
are they are they homemade baloonies i
would say
i yeah lie i'm a comic i can't lie okay
but it's freshly made from a russian
lady russian store so don't worry for a
moment there i thought
comedian
she can beat the heck out of us yeah um
she's uh she was a wrestler
um and an actress and she's gonna have
made his bleenies this is gonna be love
well that's why i'm not married if i
could cook i would be married by now
okay
is that how it works over in youtube
yeah
thank you shanti
thank you now should we eat these with
our bare hands oh no you've got four
okay it smells good
well look we've got some vodka
it's not none alcohol
no no what is this is the drink from a
drink from russia it's um
which is uh
isn't it right that's very good
very good pronunciation so it's um
[Music]
soda but it's natural herbs natural hair
naturals yeah so okay it still has some
sugar but the flavor you see is from
natural herbs so it's pretty cool so i
got this fruit smoothie today right from
my favorite fruit smoothie place but
unfortunately
the guy
when he's writing on the side of the cup
what do you want he holds the cup oh
with the inside of his fingers oh my god
while he's writing it and i was gonna
say is there a chance she could maybe
hold it in a different way but then i
worried that if i annoyed him personally
he might say right i'm going to go rub
another part of my body on the inside of
this cup when he's not watching so i
just kept quiet
like his butthole yeah how would i
approach that would you have said
anything bills i would have i'd say get
your fingers out my cup
but then really then you'd trust that
the fruit smoothie is going to make you
would be untarnished the way i'd have
said it i'd have given him the fear
so he'd have feared that i might have
kicked him in the face what about you
anya is that something that you would
talk about or would you just say you
know what i don't want it i probably
wouldn't what surprises me is that you
still drunk it
yeah
let me just taste this guy fingers yeah
i think the next time i want to go in
there i want to say something to him but
i think you should
let it let it play inside you until it
becomes a real anger well no it wasn't
an anger mine was more of a i would say
meekish thing shall i give it to you i
was going to say excuse me can i just
could i just ask you something yes
when you you're holding the cob and
writing the name yes
you're holding the cup with the inside
of your fingers and then i have to drink
from is there a chance you could hold it
from the outside no
i'm gonna go down the street to the
other place that's okay we've got your
money
thanks goodbye see you later see you
next time see everyone down here yeah
right what are we starting with the
juice first yeah let's do the juice
first what's it called again
does that translate sometimes is it just
a sound
just the sounds but actually it's funny
any time i say it now i think about it
because
now there is no meaning it just it's a
funny word actually smell it first
because the smell reminds me of
something it doesn't smell like those
animals
hang on let's have a taste yeah it
smells like aniseed balls would that be
yeah yeah
it's a nice color it's like a it's like
hulk green yeah it's like slime green
it's like a like you said it's like a
slightly herby spicy drink yeah right
here we go so in in i is it more russian
than ukraine drink i would say both
actually like our food like it's very
similar like russian ukrainian food it's
very similar do they mix it with a
little vodka um no we drink vodka
straight oh we don't mix it this is not
normal
would you mix this with anything you
could uh actually maybe a vodka would be
like a nice cocktail but we just don't
do it like we drink most of the stuff
straight and would you drink this
on a normal day yeah like now here here
yeah like my father drinks it like in
miami he goes to a
is what instead of diet coke or coke
what is that it's nice yeah i like it
i'm honestly i'm gonna have to be honest
because annie you've been very honest
with us right now i'm not sure i do like
it i do i love honesty i love honesty
it's okay but i mean to drink that as
like a coca-cola it tastes like because
it feels like you're tasting drinking
something like
pills so like yeah like samsung
prescription i don't know what it is
right
i like it okay i like the color a lot oh
yeah it's hulk green slimy green that's
really bright green right what we got
here come on on yeah okay why is there
two of them so this little one says
green chicken right that's so great
crepes crepes you know when i moved here
i called crepes crepes and i did soups
because for me it sounds very similar
i'm like what do you mean creep like
creep is a person who's like creepy yeah
no i mean like food you know like
like a creep this one is so sweet it has
a cottage cheese inside cottage cheese
yeah right we eat cottage cheese a lot
yeah sour cream and cottage cheese this
is like um
please be honest with me
that is not sure no that is much better
than i thought it was going to be when i
touched it with my finger there on you
i thought i don't like that constituency
wait what constituency yeah you've got a
political yeah
politically it's not it's not on my
street
look at that done
oh it's all coming out remember you were
talking about those little hairless dogs
you get in mexico yeah that's what it's
like pressing the tummy there oh god
that's just so i don't like that you
know like the softness and yeah but when
i
i like it
so this is more of a dessert thing
is this something you would eat for
breakfast with cup of coffee oh yeah i
would like that yeah we also make them
sometimes with chicken
eggs
but this is like the i like it the best
covers the name again blind chicken
chicken
chicken chicken yeah okay and what's the
other one here the other one seems fried
this is fried yes so this is i'm not a
fan of it but this is what i usually you
get on the streets in russia like you
know like here you get in the la tacos
understood yeah yeah this is what you
get in russia it has meat inside what
type of meat i believe it's beef
i went to smell it there on you and i
got confused and i smelt my mic
have you ever done that before when you
you forget where you are though yeah
sometimes forget it so when i taste it
for me it reminds me like of my years in
university like this will be my lunch oh
it now i was going to say is this
something that you would have if you're
a little drunk on the way home it looks
like kind of drunk yeah it is wrong it's
like after a night club on a russian bus
ooh now i like that
that's my favorite of the three
you like fed foot i do i like fatty
foods which is a shame because you're
not bulking i'm broken i'm live i'm
quite live
mmm it's good that on you good i'm glad
you like it i don't know
i think when it was fresh
i haven't encouraged me to be even
better yeah like most things how did you
get napkins
oh you didn't get one did you get one
back i got one
hang on william hold on he's passing it
on he's passed wait a minute i've got
one there it's underneath the brick
thank you very much anya have you ever
bombed on stage oh blink of them can you
talk us through your worst bomb and
maybe explain to the others out there if
they don't know what a bomb is bomb is
it's when you go on stage and you say
something and all you hear is silence
and this is the most painful thing for a
stand-up comedian if you get booed on
stage it's not as bad okay as hearing
the silence okay just nothing nothing
it's just like dead silence does it mean
that they don't really understand what
you said more than anything else because
you just don't like it you just don't
like it maybe it's not funny but yeah
it happened first time i did an open mic
and i killed it i got like it's a guy
who went in front of me he was ukrainian
he did a bunch of ukrainian stuff and i
just went after him and i just kind of
went off his material
and people were laughing like oh this is
easy stand-up comedy is easy and the
second my open mic i did i tried to do
my jokes and i bomb
i'm like oh there's a technique you need
to learn it's not that easy it has to be
some kind of a trick you know there is
this
premise and set up a punchline it's a
technique you know something that you
can learn
um it's painful when you're on stage but
i used to be like very upset sometimes i
could drive my car like oh my gosh i'm
not funny this is so bad but then you
take it from another perspective like
okay let me take all the audience as my
writing partners
okay so they're here to help me so if
they're not laughing okay i need to work
on the joke or drop the joke or change
something in it and if they're laughing
okay this is
but there are ways of doing that now
when i had experience like i'm like okay
if they're not laughing i can say it
okay it's not funny you guys are not
laughing and then they start laughing
you know i'm like okay you just have to
like kind of embrace the truth yeah like
okay i didn't do well tonight you just
lead into the thing that scares you
that's painful and everybody bombs right
everybody reminds me of the rem song
everybody bombs sometimes i'm not sure
about that last note oh sorry about that
um yeah even the best guys
will have moments on stage where they're
like yeah i guess that didn't really
yeah it's like one you have like name
and industry like people gonna laugh at
you with you more because out of respect
like you'll see something coming but
even then like i've seen big guys like
okay this is not working let me change
it to another topic it's it happens it
happens to everybody it's just a beauty
of set up comedy like
it's never ending it's like you think
you have success and you're like okay
there's another level i need to create
new material new material like you know
now you've got all this stuff from a
russian store in town is that right and
yeah
are there places in la where you can
access all the things that you might
miss from where you yeah i found one in
encino which is like 10 minutes drive
from you guys lovely um very cool place
called raspution oh yeah yeah so they're
good and i know it's fresh like they
make it right says the kitchen is kind
of a little bit open so you can see yeah
that's fresh yeah there are a couple of
places there's one in topanga
soju city it's like three or four places
we mark them don't we don't we give them
scores
and uh the scores are based on the taste
of course how it looks
and how useful is it in your kitchen if
you have it now should we put it all as
one thing
as one sort of russian family i think we
can tom so the overall vibe of the
overall vibe of this because it looks
like zero
no we're averaging nobody
in fact this the last one i'm absolutely
loving i'm trying to save room for
dinner tonight billy cause billy and i
are gonna have a wonderful sushi
extravaganza but i love this thing i
like the taste i like the taste of
everything to be honest as a taste all
in as a russian tasting meal i'm gonna
have to give that and we do it out of
10. i'm going to have to give that
an 8.9 my god that's high that's a high
high you're too nice to me
it's delicious he's actually not a nice
person no so he wouldn't he wouldn't try
and save you you know by being a
pleasant guy he can be deeply unpleasant
yeah
so you're just being honest there 8.9
gosh
i have to say
i know we're taking it on an average
the juice has brought down the average
score to me and the fried delicacy has
pumped it up right now yeah little soft
guys in the meat in the middle meet it
in the middle i'm going to give it a 7.3
that's all right that costs more
like seven points yeah oh yeah we get
vegetables
why men always like to give numbers to
everything to women to food
women it's me and and more so in america
america love numbers they love numbers
which is a shame i'm terrible with
numbers
oh we should like talk about this yeah
yeah well what's uh what's 9 plus 14
well that's 23
hang
on 25
well done
yeah did you do it like that yeah just
math that that's just math that's
amazing yeah thanks anya do you want to
give it an average score well i would
give it to six so i think it's not a bad
taste that's well
that's okay how does it look dom what
the aesthetics of it well
the guys brought it down with his little
his little tummy yeah the little guy
with the cottage cheese explosion inside
i'm not really into and the lovely fried
delicacy just looks like a folded over
pancake i will give a little bit of an
extra score because i like you was
delighted by the slime green color it's
quite it's quite a green isn't it yeah
it's a healthy grain so that's pumped it
up to a 6.2
that's not bad tom yeah it doesn't it
doesn't look great it doesn't look like
you know anything i haven't seen before
except for the green yeah so because of
green we'll give it a
7.2 right
and yeah you want to give us
your thoughts for how it looks how it
looks yeah
it doesn't look good no no it's like you
see like sometimes delicious and
beautiful
but beautiful but i don't think it's
beautiful right i would give it like
three or four minutes it's only getting
a three or four i knew you know we'll
call it 3.5 you're quite strict against
your own nation's food
you'll find out with people that have
been world champions that they're very
specific
how useful is it
if you've got it in the kitchen is there
other things you can do with it like
could you open that up you can open it
up yes so and then scrape out the stuff
and make a cake a cake um no you can
actually this is like already folded
yeah but you can actually make it like
unfold it and let people just put their
own cottages in it mm-hmm okay like you
kind of like instead of like being super
like fat and like you know like you can
just choose whatever ingredients you
want but if it was in your fridge and
you had leftovers and you had that and
you had three eggs and a pint of milk
and and you couldn't say oh i'll cut
that up and i'll make it into it
well i think the fried thing not that
i've ever had it but i think the fried
thing with like a poached egg on top
sounds fantastic little egg
breakfast into it
except if someone made it for you you
know dom will not eat an egg if someone
else is made don't eat other people's
eggs on you why
i just have a thing about it i like eggs
yeah which is weird because obviously
the eggs aren't mine the chicken's eggs
but when i get them from the supermarket
then i take ownership of them
and then if someone were to come into my
house and say you sit there watch the
football i'll make you a couple of
scrambled eggs i think i'm not gonna eat
those but if i make them i'll eat them
what about other food like if it would
be like like someone else's toast
[Music]
i'm a little weird with with dairy stuff
like
milk i'm gonna need to give it a bit of
a once-over you know like if someone
says you want milk in your tea i would
look at it from a distance and go
no i'm okay i'll just have it
i'm you know apart from that
i'm okay from a distance
not sure if any other people's ice cream
wouldn't you no it might be a dairy
product if there's anyone out there that
has the same kind of issue and has got
to the bottom of it i'd love to hear
from you what about you is there
anything that you but outside of that is
there anything that you absolutely will
not eat like i do not like eating uh
pigs i wouldn't eat rabbit like you know
in russian traditionally people eat
rabbits oh do you is that a russian
galaxy yeah a lot and i remember i was
like five six years old and my mom
cooked a rabbit and they told me during
the dinner i started crying hysterically
i'm like i'm not going to interrupt for
me it's like a cat like eating a cat you
know like they're pretty they have fur
like something you pet so this is one
thing like i wouldn't eat my dad when he
was younger walked past a butcher's
shop
and there's a sign in the butcher's shop
that said water ship down
you've read the book you've seen the
film
now eat the cast
and he had a whole bunch of rabbits
hanging in the window he's not brilliant
though that's brilliant it's brilliant
okay so you won't eat rabbit apparently
not you okay
is there anything that you won't eat
well you know i was pescetarian i only
ate fish for about 15 years wow until
about
three or four months ago and i started
eating meat again and i don't know why i
don't know why i started eating meat
again but
maybe i'll stop soon but at the moment
i'm enjoying it i'm bulking i might have
mentioned you have to listen to your
body like i was a vegetarian for a year
and after that i'm like one day i was
just craving steak so badly i'm like you
know what i'm just gonna eat the steak
yeah it's weird doesn't it it's weird
nothing's ever permanent you know so a
lot of people make these kind of
absolutes i'm this yeah then a couple
years later when you're not that someone
says i thought you said you were there
you go well i was then no but now i'm
different i was 40. now i'm 45. do you
know what i mean things change this is
what yes you're right don't give
yourself a hard time i'm not giving
myself a hard time usefulness
it's not very useful dom well as well as
you get your skills you can't even you
know what i mean as what is is it yeah
and i don't know if i'd make a smoothie
from it i don't even i would just like
the greenness of it you could use the
greenness to color the sponge of a cake
and you can make like a incredible hulk
cake i'll tell you a conversation i had
in the surf the other day we went for a
surfing holiday i mean my son last week
and i was sitting in the water and this
guy paddled over and he says what color
would you say this water is oh i said i
think it's green right and he says what
green
all right and i said i don't know maybe
lime green or something lime green and
one of the other surfers said i think
it's emerald oh that's lovely and i
thought that's nice and then another guy
came up he paddled over he'd a mullet
and he says the fish or the hairstyle
the hairstyle and he says i think it's
pistachio green oh come on guys and i
said
pistachio green
i said where did you get that from he
said there's a place down the street
that does ice lollies yeah and they do a
pistachio one and it's exactly the same
color as this water but pistachios are
pale green surely see when i paddled out
dom me and my son get in the car we went
down to that shop and we had a pistachio
ice lolly and it was the same color as
that one so the emerald guy was way off
because emerald is a deep mysterious
green it's dark yeah it's dark like that
yeah almost like that oh yeah i would
say similar that feels more like a
forest screen to me but i'm colorblind
so i have no idea but that was a good
story wasn't it was a great story thank
you well it's not very useful i can only
give it
a two i disagree i think the fried dish
if you chop that up and added it with a
little bit of like rice or pasta it'd be
a nice little thing you could put an egg
on it not sure that this is very useful
but i also think the fizzy drink the
color of it you can use so i'm going to
pump it up a little bit i'm going to say
a 4.9
and yeah i would give it a five five in
between you know you can do something
with it but not much yeah it's just like
you can do something this is good for
alcohol i'm assuming right after our
conversation you can mix it with do you
ever have russian evenings at your house
and yeah where you invite people over
too much you have like i do but my
landlord is dutch we just had a dutch
party i should do a russian party
that was fun did he make dutch
delicacies sausages a bunch of meat did
you have dream cake what a drink we had
a dutch guy on wait a minute casper no
he was danish i'm sorry
if you have a russian
time round at your house invite me and
donald would love to come yes i should
make a russian party
and also you could say to your guests as
a surprise i'm going to invite these two
hobbits over and they don't know but i'm
going to use them both as punching bags
to show you guys just how hard i can
kick and you could kick me and the body
and billionaire oh yeah well he doesn't
like to keep the head no i don't like to
get hurt or would you rather get kicked
in the head or the body you can choose
the
leg all the legs
okay
it hurts
i wouldn't go body after seeing ufc this
year you can you can keep me in the head
and i'll look forward to it okay but
everybody please go and see on yeah at
our stand-up shows and uh whatever else
she gets up to and make laughs not war
let's all go and see those shows when
they come on do lots of them please yeah
yeah if there's anything in particular
that you want people to know about you
can tell them now yeah about just follow
me on instagram i post all the shows
here make love's not war hopefully
october caroline's new york
i'm gonna do bunch shows in l.a it's
better to follow him on instagram
everybody what is your instagram anya
underscores
well annie it's been lovely having you
on
thank you for educating us about a whole
bunch of stuff thank you for giving me a
bunch of stuff make sure you um
leave us all your questions comments and
concerns on our youtube page that's the
french bunion
and don't forget to send your artwork
because we're going to have the special
art
fanart for our episode on the 5th or
around about the 5th of september i
don't know where you send it because
we're in a new studio yeah you cure it's
down below check it out in the show
notes and also if you subscribe and rate
and reviewers we can make more and more
shows and you can come check us out in
toronto at the fan expo billy and i will
do we'll be doing a birthday
extravaganza podcast
for billy's birthday so bring your gifts
and your kisses guys we'll see you next
week see you next week on a friendship
onion toodles
[Music]
harmonize with me and hold me tight all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your boy's the baby you're my pearl